all right speaking of the patriot way
and bill belichick
tom brady finds his way out of new
england and the big question for the
patriots is who will the quarterback be
they've seen an exodus of plenty of free
agents led by brady jared stidham is on
the roster andy dalton is still
available cam newton may be cut and i
think as soon as today by the carolina
panthers because they're not going to
find a trade partner for him what do you
think bill belichick does to fill that
quarterback position top of the depth
chart week one of the 2020 season who do
you think it's going to be
well now that duke tobin has told ian
rappaport that we would work with andy
dalton on possibly finding him a new
place to play or whatever he did and i'm
paraphrasing that if i'm wrong it's
something like that
now that duke tobin has said that
what prevents
every team in the nfl now that there are
not really a lot of teams left mike if
you think about it what the chargers
obviously the patriots
if you're the patriots
right now if you're the patriots
what prevents you from saying cut them
and then signing andy dalton one year
seven million prove it contract has a
and and they they agree with him at the
end of this
we won't tag you
you know so in other words then you
don't have to pay andy dalton 17 you
could just pay him seven
or and and again because my point is
that
bellatrix gonna sit on the sidelines
and just wait and see all these team all
these quarterbacks
who uh you know need a place to play
they got a sign somewhere
so
they may have to use 2020
as a
audition moment
even though they've been quality good
nfl starters in the case of cam newton
and mvp
why wouldn't the new england patriots
just say
on may first we'll sign somebody we'll
just see who's out there because
they're not all that concerned with who
it is
in my opinion is and i've said this all
along i have zero inside information on
this zero but in my opinion
all along andy dalton has been a perfect
patriots guy
egoless dude
a hard worker will do anything that they
say never complains
he's got the patriot ethos
and again for some reason
hard for me to picture cam newton that
way you know the cam newton i've seen in
training camp with being the the dancer
and the yeller and the
and again that's fine that's who he is
and a lot of teams that's wonderful
probably 25 teams that's wonderful just
can't imagine it happen in new england
but again i don't know mike i think they
wait
and they look at the pool of
quarterbacks whatever it is
on april 29th may 3rd whatever it is and
they pick
one uh you know i agree with you about
cam newton i'm fascinated by what newton
could do with the patriots because he's
2-0 all time against the new england
patriots and bill belichick has had a
hell of a time with mobile quarterbacks
and i'd love to see them get one and
that brings me back to taysom hill we
haven't heard much about him this week
other than there's a first round tender
that was applied to the restricted free
agent 4.6 million dollars anyone can
make him an offer and usually that kind
of stuff happens after the first wave of
free agency but do you think the
patriots will take a look at maybe
trying to snag taste some hill give up
their first round pick pay tay some hill
get him from the saints assuming they
wouldn't match i think they're gonna
match whatever offer is made
but if i'm bill belichick i'm intrigued
by what taysom hill could be if josh
mcdaniels and belichick craft an offense
to get the most out of him
there's no question about it i think
it's an intriguing thing to do it just
depends how much cash you have in year
one and how much cash you could put into
that contract the saints are not in
great cap shape
i think if somebody did sign taysom hill
that what the saints would have to do
is redo about five contracts because
they're determined that taysom hill gets
a first shot in 2021 or whenever tom
brady leaves i'm good tom brady drew
brees leaves so
i look at this right now i think taysom
hill would be great for them
but i'm a little concerned
honestly that uh
that the patriots
would hand the reins to taysom hill
and give them the kind of contract
that they would have to give him without
really knowing
this would be the ultimate leap of faith
by bill belichick does anybody really
know it was funny mike i looked at his
stats at brigham young i don't know one
time this year i looked them up
they were not very good
you know and again you don't it's hard
to tell that obviously
but wow
that would be a gutsy call by the
patriots because
they have to put a lot of money into the
first year of the contract for the
saints not to match
yeah absolutely absolutely and and uh
sean payton believes in him but whether
that translates to any other team that
remains to be seen it's a fascinating
possibility though because of the
mobility that he brings to the table and
the patriots haven't had a guy like that
and they've had issues defending guys
like that throughout the course of the
last 20 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports